foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor Hello friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact
in February 2014 a northern California
couple out walking their dog on their
country property east of Sacramento they
stumbled across a modern day pot of gold
actually they found several pots of gold
buried in the shadow of an old oak tree
the couple who had chosen to remain
anonymous found eight tin cans
containing
1427 gold coins dating between 1847 and
1894. virtually all of them in mint
condition
although the face value of the gold
pieces only adds up to about twenty
seven thousand dollars some of the coins
are so rare and well preserved coin
experts expect they could fetch easily
up to one million dollars
it's believed whoever owned the property
150 years ago buried the coins as a kind
of primitive safety deposit box then
probably died taking the secret with
them
this once in a lifetime horde that could
easily fetch 10 million dollars is
believed to be the most valuable buried
treasure ever found in the United States
you know Pastor Russ the Bible also
tells about a man who found buried
treasure in a field that's right Pastor
Doug after hearing that fact you want to
go get a shovel and start digging around
in your yard you never know we're not
far from where the story actually took
place here in Northern California that's
right no matter what else is out there
today uh our family just went kayaking
down the American river with our
granddaughter Lily hello Lily and our
son and uh we went right through the
country where they found that gold and
the guide said you know they're they're
panning out there right now we saw
people panty for gold because they keep
finding gold in the American River and
the story I reference is in Matthew 13
verse 44 and it says again the Kingdom
of Heaven is like a treasure hidden in a
field which a man found and hid and for
Joy of it he goes and he sells all that
he has and buys the field so Jesus
pictures the story you know back then
poor people used to at least land for
farming and while he's out plowing this
land it's not his land but he's doing
something then he finds this treasure
people didn't have Banks they buried
their treasure back then
and um then you realize he's an honest
man he says he hit it again yeah it
covers it up and he goes and he
negotiates to buy the field but it's
going to cost him everything but he
knows what it's worth so he sells
everything and Jesus uses that as an
analogy or Parable to explain that
the kingdom of heaven and eternal life
is worth everything what could be worth
more
you know we have a book that talks about
this it's called The Riches of his grace
it's the greatest treasure that anyone
can ever find is the truth as it is in
Jesus and we'll send this to you for
free all you have to do is call the
number
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line and ask for the book it's called
The Riches of his grace you can also
dial pound 250 on your smartphone and
just say Bible answers live as for the
book The Riches of his grace and we'll
be happy to send it to anyone here in
the U.S or outside or North America I
guess it is if you're outside of North
America then just got our website
amazingfacts.org if you have a Bible
question the phone line here at the
studio is
800-463-7297 that will bring you right
here if you don't get through right away
please just be patient we'll get to as
many calls as possible we'll pass it out
before we go to the phone lines let's
start with the word of Prayer
dear father we thank you for your word
we thank you for the opportunity to
study the Bible and let me just pray for
your guidance and the Holy Spirit to be
with us here in the studio and be with
the many who are listening wherever they
might be Lord guide us into a clearer
understanding of what the Bible says in
Jesus name amen amen well our first
caller this evening we've got Gary
listening in Illinois Gary welcome to
the program
thank you in Genesis 11 verses 6 and 7
it says that God confused the language
of the people building the Tower of
Babel because all the people spoke the
same language and there would be nothing
impossible for them so is there anything
in the Bible that talks about the
development of A.I you know the
conversations I heard on YouTube says
that AI is sentient that it has
Consciousness it thinks something on its
own so this is going to be a have a big
impact on society in a big way and so
uh I'm just wondering if there's
anything in the Bible about it also that
the AI said it didn't believe in a deity
that's interesting you know just before
we came on the air and I had not seen
your question yet Pastor Ross and I were
talking about AI meaning artificial
intelligence I think most people know
that
and that is a fascinating question you
know Jesus does warn Us in the last days
that the deceptions will be so effective
and overwhelming that if it were
possible even the very elect would be
deceived now while I I don't agree with
some of the experts that are saying that
uh artificial intelligence has a
conscience right now all that artificial
intelligence does is it responds to
programming and it is true that there
are programs that are then being trained
to uh analyze is what they're doing but
as far as having you know I believe the
Holy Spirit speaks to our minds and
gives us a conscience and convicts I
don't think that AI has that it's it's a
computer program but uh are there
dangerous yes look at what it does today
and just imagine what it's going to look
like in five years we had a men's
meeting this morning we talked about Ai
and I don't have time to share
everything but uh the presenter did a
good job of even tying in some
scriptures about
like when the serpent suddenly spoke he
had this extra intelligence that Eve was
intrigued by
and um you know what they're doing now
with taking a segment of a person's
voice and some of their pictures and
they're creating video of this person
talking and they they may have been dead
I mean all you need is some of their
audio files and video files and they now
can kind of recreate them which is like
a Consulting evil spirits or dead
Spirits so I think there's some very
interesting moral dilemmas not that all
AI is bad
virtually every company is using it in
some you know if you have a smartphone
you're using AI you may not even know it
but I think it's going to play a role in
how the beast power is going to control
buying and selling in the last days all
right well thank you for your cool Gary
and uh next call is Jerry Jerry in Texas
Jerry welcome to the program okay guys
thank you uh you opened up with a bag of
worms tonight you have ai there and I'm
going to give follow-up to the question
I'm going to ask you okay it could could
it be construed
as uh playing with AI or interacting
with AI could that be construed as
playing with a Ouija board and I base
this on eight days ago we had a uh
amazing facts Sabbath School study hour
that we have uh weekly on amazing facts
and the gentleman uh referred to a young
boy that was 12 to 14 years old and he
was uh interacting with a bot
and he asked the bot
who is your creator in the bot
respondent saying my father is a fallen
angel from heaven
oh that's interesting when you start
dabbling with using Ai and trying to get
spiritual advice from a computer I think
the devil can influence that and I
wouldn't recommend that now again I want
to explain that when I'm typing a
document and it is auto correcting that
is a very simple form of AI so AI in
itself is a technology
and like television or printing press or
you know so many Technologies can be
used for good or evil
and I I think there's no question that
AI the devil can use it for evil but
that doesn't mean all AI is bad I think
part of the concern in talking about AI
is is people put so much trust in you
know what their phone says are we just
talking about this on the way home after
the meeting this morning and if somebody
asks well what's the population of
Sacramento and somebody pull out there
everyone says well I think it's this
let's think it's that and then they ask
Google and Google give an answer and
that is the final answer once Google
says or whatever your phone tells you
the answers as if all right that's the
final word there's a lot of trust built
into Ai and you wonder what that
confidence that people have in
artificial intelligence is that
something that the devil can manipulate
in the end of time and computers do make
mistakes that's right I've uh I've taken
I followed a GPS down a road that ended
up being filled with trees and there was
no road but it sewed my GPS said forward
they can mislead you sometimes all right
thank you Jerry we've got Anthony
listening in New York Anthony welcome to
Bible answers live
good evening pastors evening really
quick
when I asked the question a few months
back about um ambition and you know in
the Christian walk and things of that
nature and
um based on the answer to your my
question from you
um I applied for a promotion I actually
got it and it's a pretty high position
in the company so I just want to say
thank you for that um for that word from
the Lord and uh praying that I'll be
faithful like Daniel or Joseph
and so my question is um
has to do with uh the Shekinah Glory so
we know from Exodus that in the
sanctuary in the wilderness that I
believe the pillar of cloud when it
stopped
um we believe that the pillow cloud is
Jesus was a form of you know
pre-incarnate Jesus Christ and the
pillar of fire as well and that pillar
of cloud once the sanctuary was built to
filled the temple
with the glory of the Lord and so I
guess my understanding is that the
Shekinah Glory correct me if I'm wrong
it's the kind of Glory is was Jesus
Christ the presence of Jesus Christ
among the people and so when Christ came
to the earth when he was born
um
was this kind of Glory still in the
temple before it was destroyed in 80 70
and and uh and and you know and I know
the temple the veil in the temple was
rent when Christ died signifying the end
of the sanctuary service so because
Christ was here physically on Earth was
the Shekinah still in the temple within
nosikana and the Jews were you know
doing the sacrificial service without
the Shekinah understood yeah the um the
Shekinah Glory never really reappeared
in the temple following the time of
um Josiah when Nebuchadnezzar conquered
uh Jerusalem and the Ark was hidden the
Ark of the Covenant they Shekinah Glory
always appeared above the Ark of the
Covenant it never appeared again there's
no record I should say of it appearing
again because the ark was gone it's like
uh back when the ark was captured by the
Philistines in the days of Eli they said
Ichabod the glory is is uh departed so I
think the glory worry that visible
manifestation of God's presence was gone
from the temple from the time of
Nebuchadnezzar when they rededicated the
temple in the days of Ezra and Nehemiah
they never saw the Shekinah Glory come
down like they did in the days of David
or in Solomon's time
so when Christ was on earth and the veil
ripped it was signifying that the old
ceremonial system had ended
but I don't think anything happened with
the Shekinah Glory did you have any you
know I agree I think uh after you know
the temple was rebuilt it spoke of the
latter house or the second house having
greater glory than the first house
because Christ went in to teach them
right so it wasn't the Shekinah Glory
which was glorious in the time of
Solomon the glory it was even grading
the person of Christ so there was no
need for another Shekinah Glory if the
glory of Christ was greater than what
was revealed there in the Shekinah and
then of course when the veil ran from
top to bottom it signified that the
temple and and Jesus said your house is
left to you yes so he said destroy this
Temple I will build one made without
hands meaning his body the church
very good I'm thinking do we have a
study we do have a study guide on the
temple it's called Uh God built like I
drew the plants gone through the plans
that's what it is one of amazing fact
study guides we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is 800-835-6747
as for the study guide It's called God
through the plans I'll be happy to send
it to you or just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and say Bible answers live
and ask for that by name we've got
Thomas listening Canada Thomas welcome
to Bible answers live
Hey Thomas you're on the air yeah yes
thank
you and your question
the question is yes
um the other expressed by pastors that
um and this is not a common
understanding but that there's a book of
creation and then there's the book of
God's word and and as there's two
witnesses that that God had to
um Carry Out To Death because of
breaking the law he required a minimum
of two witnesses so God follows that
same principle that's why creation and
word there are in harmony so my
particular question is which I
Illustrated to this
to the um interviewer when she started
is that carbon has a signature of 666.
and oxygen has a signature of 888
and Jesus name adds up to 888 in Greek
the language of the New Testament was
written the common language of the day
so my question is do we see an imprint
of God putting salvation in creation by
those two numbers
okay I've never had that question before
I have heard before that um carbon was
somehow reflected by the Numbers 666 I
don't know maybe the the something in
the in the uh molecular structure yeah
and the elements uh of it I I I don't
know that I would try to use that kind
of math taking the name of Jesus and the
numerical value of his name in Hebrew
and saying you know part of it equals
um the earth and the word and creation
you know when I get to heaven I think
we're going to learn a lot about
numerology God does use a lot of
interesting numbers in the Bible and
we'll probably understand it better
there are math geniuses that see all
kinds of connections
of course if you look in nature you can
see the great controversy played out you
see good and evil yeah revealed in
nature you see beauty nature but you
also see pain and suffering so just by
looking at nature you realize well first
of all there must be a Creed but you
also realize that there's an adversary
that brings suffering and death and then
of course the Bible expounds upon that
yep something you can see something went
wrong it's a beautiful world and yet
there's sin and suffering and death so
hey thank you Thomas I don't know if
that helps at all we do have we do have
a free
um download it's at a website called
Bible
a Bible prophecy .com is that right
where to get the study on numbers
oh yeah Bible prophecy truth prophecy
code if their webs are still up
no it's well it may be there too yeah
okay
anyway yeah we we've got if you type in
amazing facts Bible numbers and their
meanings I think we have a resource on
that George listening in Texas George
welcome to Bible answers live
uh hi pastors hi how can we help you
okay I know that uh one of The
Commandments is Thou shalt not kill thou
shall not murder does that mean I'm
automatically supposed to vote for the
party of the pro-life and if I vote for
the other party
that's not pro-life am I sinning
well that's an interesting question
um personally
I I think that you need to evaluate what
the the values are of different
candidates
um you probably could find good and evil
in both in both parties unfortunately
um so you know sometimes when the time
comes to to vote you need to pray and
then hold your nose and vote as an
American citizen
um
I I personally would have a moral
problem and again I don't want to make
political statements we want to give
Bible answers I would have a problem
personally voting for a candidate that
was supporting abortion
um
and that might mean that you know you're
voting for a candidate who's supporting
some things in other areas that are not
biblical but to me it's a pretty serious
violation when you're taking innocent
life you know one of the councils I
heard dealing with voting it's always
good if you can to vote on specific
issues versus just then parties in
general because like you say there's
good and bad in each of the parties but
if you have the opportunity to vote on a
specific issue whether that's pro-life
or abortion or how What is marriage
defined as uh we as Christians I think
have an opportunity to um
stand for what the Bible says on these
issues so vote on on issues if possible
yep very good thank you George we got
Joel listening pardon me I do have a
book we do that's called a Christian
vote yeah and it talks a little bit Yeah
it becomes real popular you know
relaxing season yeah but we'll send it
to anyone who calls and asks the number
for that is
800-835-6747 just ask for the book
should a Christian vote and we'll be
happy to send it to you or dial pound
250 on your smartphone and you can get
it that way as well Jolly North Carolina
Joel welcome to the program
good evening pastors good evening I'm
doing a study on the timeline between
the the Triumph entry and
the uh
amount of Olives where Jesus told the
cycles that you know the jerusal was
going to be destroyed my question is did
that from
Matthew 21
to Matthew 26.
did that that happened though for like a
three-day period right
well it yeah it's it's a matter of a few
days I'd have to go back and look at
chapter 21 I know that most of the
gospels are dedicated most of their time
to the final week of Christ's life
um so it wouldn't surprise me Matthew 21
yeah I think that's where Jesus is
excoriating the scribes and Pharisees
yeah I think from if you're looking at
Matthew 21 starting in verse 1 all the
way through to the crucifixion it's
about a week
so um various Bible scholars believe
that Jesus came to Jerusalem or Bethany
which was two miles outside of Jerusalem
on the Friday he was there for the
Sabbath and then on Sunday he entered
Triumph and entering into Jerusalem and
then of course that Friday was crucified
so a lot happened within that one week
it tells about yeah several teaching
episodes and the cursing the Fig Tree
when he went in and out okay thank you
Joel uh who do we have next chesty yeah
is that right Chastity Chastity from
Arizona Chastity welcome to the program
hi thank you very much yes
um I just have a question
um are the demons that are mentioned in
the Bible the fallen angels and who are
the third of the Fallen Angels who fell
to Earth
yeah
um yes and yes
the the Angels the the evil spirits are
the same as the Fallen Angels so uh you
know the devil is sometimes referred to
as an evil spirit
um you know we don't wrestle against
flesh and blood it says in Ephesians
chapter six but against spiritual hosts
of evil and high places
and in Revelation 12 it says Satan was
cast out of heaven and his angels were
cast out with him and then you eat
earlier the tale of the Dragon Drew one
third of the stars and these the stars
are the dragon is a symbol for Satan and
the stars are a symbol for the Angels
um and it says his angels were cast down
with him so
whenever we hear about evil spirits and
sometimes they're called demons or even
ghosts these are typically Angels
Satan's Angels they're fallen angels
that have been converted like Lucifer
Satan was once Lucifer he was the chief
of the angels and he became a devil
and the Fallen Angels became demons
we have a study guide that talks about
the origin of evil it's called The God
created devil and I think it addresses
this very question about the angels and
how they fell if you'd like receive that
the number to call these
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide did
God create the devil or dial pound 250
on your smartphone and just ask for it
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks we've got Joel listening
in Arizona Joel welcome to the program
how you guys doing great
how are you doing hey uh my question
this week is um
I watched uh
uh Pastor Patrick I watched your um
presentation on the 144 000 but I never
really got a definitive answer of who
they are
and so I guess my question would be
since the Bible says that before the the
four quarters or the the
end times the angels are released to
wreak havoc on the Earth right that the
angel goes and he seals the 144 000 yes
is it possible that the 144 000 could be
the actual literal number of people that
get Co with the Seal of God before the
tribulation
I I don't think they're the only ones
uh in other words I think everyone in
the last days said saved has the Seal of
God because everyone else has got the
mark of the beast but the hundred and
forty four thousand I think there's more
than just 144 000 that are saved I think
the 144 000 represent the leadership uh
keep in mind Revelation is written by an
apostle his name is John and everything
you read about the 144 000 fits the
definitions of the Apostles they follow
the lamb wherever he goes it says these
are they without guile uh they have a
special message
um it's like on the day of Pentecost
one of the disciples had committed
suicide because he betrayed Jesus Judas
and before the holy spirit is poured out
Peter says we need to replace that
because we're down to 11 Apostles as
soon as they get to the number 12 the
next thing it says is the place they
were gathered together is shaken and the
Holy Spirit is poured out when they got
to that number 12 there's something
about that and I think that in the same
way God used 12 Apostles
to go and preach to the Lost tribes of
Israel during Jesus first coming
he's going to have 12 times 12 000
before the second coming they're not the
only ones saved just like on the day of
Pentecost you've got 12 Apostles in the
upper room but there's 120 total there's
other people other disciples there
it wasn't just the 12 apostles filled
with the Holy Spirit it was everybody in
the upper room and then through their
preaching there's a great Revival and I
think that's going to repeat itself a
lot of rain outpouring of the spirit the
144 000 are a type of God's people but
they're they're symbol for the apostles
also
I've got a book we can send you we may
have offered this to you last time but I
don't know if you received it yet or
asked for it but it's on who are the
hundred and forty four thousand
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
we'll be happy to send it to you Joel or
anyone wanting to learn more about
Revelation chapter 7 dial pound 250 on
your smartphone and just say Bible
answers live and again you can ask for
the book I'll be happy to send it to you
next holder that we have is James
listening from Pennsylvania James
welcome to the program
hi good evening I was wondering if I
could ask two really quick questions if
I'm uh real quick to make my point okay
let's take them one at a time
sure the first question I have is are
God's people allowed to defend
themselves and their families from the
forces of evil without committing sin
say like if somebody tried to break into
my house and the only way that I could
defend my family is like if I had to
shoot them or something
you know according to the Bible uh it
says pretty clearly even Jesus said that
you know you can't break into a strong
men's house unless you bind him first
physically you have to restrain him
meaning that if you don't physically
restrain him he's going to defend his
family
and so I think it's a pretty common
Universal understanding that a man or
whoever is in the house would want to
protect the home and the children and
the occupants and so uh if force is used
to come in you might need to use Force
if you can to stop an invasion and most
laws in most countries understand and
recognize that so I don't think there's
a moral you know some people might say
you know I just I can't do that even if
my family is at risk and I'd
respectfully disagree but there are some
people who feel so strongly about any
kind of uh what they would call violent
defense
um
that they they don't think a Christian
should do that they should just pray
well I I want to bother my conscience
I think it's normal reaction and I think
it's even a duty for the man of a house
to protect and provide for his family uh
listening friends
um
we want to thank you for your continued
support of amazing facts now we've still
got half the program to come but I just
want to pause here this program is a
hundred percent supported by you and if
you've been blessed we encourage you to
go to the website and keep us going
don't go away the best of Bible answers
live is coming in our second half
foreign
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
would you like to know God's plan for
our broken world as revealed in Bible
prophecy
want practical trusted solutions for
your biggest challenges freshly updated
and redesigned amazing facts Bible study
guides provide 27 bible-based topical
lessons with beautiful graphics and
straightforward answers that are
enlightening encouraging and easy to
understand
study guide leads you step by step to
real relevant Bible answers for the most
important questions in your life how can
I have better health in relationships
when and how will Jesus come again and
so much more
don't leave the future to chance
form your life with truths from The
Amazing Facts Bible study guides
order your complete set today by
visiting afbookstore.com or by calling
800-538-7275
find out whether critics are raving
about top Scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the Book of
Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the Book of
Revelation like never before Revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
at iTunes or afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible-related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back to listening friends the
Bible answers live and if you've tuned
in somewhere along the way this is a
live International interactive Bible
study and you're invited to call in with
your Bible questions if you don't get
through right away we'll try again seek
and you will find and uh the knock and
it'll be open it's 800 God says is the
phone number one more time
800-463-7297 and my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross we're
going to go to Aaron listening in New
York Aaron welcome to Bible answers live
good evening pastors evening
I encountered an internet's troll on the
comment section of a Christian YouTube
video
he claims that God created sin because
the Bible says God created all things
and he counts sin as a thing because he
defines a thing as which is considered a
separate entity object quality and
concept
he uses Romans chapter 11 verse 36 to
back up his claim my question is can sin
be included in the meaning behind Romans
chapter 6 chapter 11 verse 36 and uh
Colossians chapter 1 verses 16 and 17.
well let's read these for friends who
are listening uh in Romans chapter 11 36
for of him and through him uh and to him
are all things to whom be the glory
forever well what all things is Paul
talking about you go to verse 33 says of
the depth of the riches of the wisdom of
the knowledge of God he's talking about
the mercy of God in verse 31 and God's
grace he's not talking about evil and so
he's Paul is saying that the the glory
for all the Plan of Salvation belongs to
God we can't take credit for it so that
that verse I think to say that God
created sin now there's a big problem
with anyone who says that God created
sin it says God tempts no man James says
I forget the verse God cannot be tempted
with evil neither does he tempt anybody
so whoever tempted Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden God never induces people
to sin God does not create entrapment to
try to get people to sin he hates sin
that's James chapter 1 verse 13. yes God
does intent every good and perfect gift
is from God and comes down from the
Father of Lights with whom there is no
variableness or shadow of turning and so
God is good
um sin came from God created a good
Angel who had a free will and this
intelligent free moral being Lucifer
he became selfish his sin began with him
and uh God is good God is pure God is
just so the idea that God created sin
created Sinners and then said he's going
to punish Sinners for being Sinners well
that would make God an accomplice to the
problem of sin which really would uh go
against everything the Bible says about
God hating sin of course we have that
study guide says did God create a devil
and it deals with us I'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
that's
800-835-6747 or dial pound 250 on your
smartphone yeah sorry just In fairness
also I think Aaron was also asking about
Colossians 1 16 and 17 which is also
seen I believe that God made all things
but we're talking about God made
everything it looks back to Genesis
where it says it was good good very good
he made everything good
and because of the choice of one of the
free creatures Adam and Eve and the
devil they made moral choices not to
love and not to obey
all right thanks for your call Aaron
we've got uh Lawrence listening from
Oregon Lawrence welcome to the program
yeah uh
about the symptoms
told us to follow his steps and he was
synthesized on the 8th wave
who do we practice second season today
or not people
apologies that's my question yeah well
one of the big discussions they had in
the New Testament is as the Gentiles
were coming to Christ and believing in
Jesus some of the Jewish Believers in
Christ said oh well they need to be
circumcised and there was a long
discussion about this in the early
church and they came to the conclusion
that it is not necessary circumcision
was something that pointed to the
Covenant that the promised seed would
come through the line of Abraham it also
was a symbol for The Cutting away of the
flesh not being carnally minded but
being spiritual minded so now many
countries and peoples I think Muslims
and Jews and many Gentiles today still
practice circumcision and they perform
it in hospitals routinely for G's and
Gentiles because there is some medical
benefit now I'm talking about male
circumcision and female circumcision is
believed to be not all negative is it's
kind of a mutilation but um and you can
probably research the details of that on
your own but uh there's no command
pulse's circumcision is nothing and you
can read this in Galatians
uncircumcision is nothing keeping the
Commandments is what matters
okay thank you we've got uh Judith
listening in Nevada Judith welcome to
Bible answers live
hello good evening my question is we
need to do
Genesis Chapter 3 of verses 1 to 23 is
about the the character of the snake
we know that God
describe the the snake as the most guile
among the animals in the garden some
people would even put in a sermon that
the devil is smart and I really would
like to
to address this that if the devil is
smart the devil should not have become
the devil he would still be one of the
Caribbeans
um guarding the Ark of the Covenant and
the meaning of God here is actually it's
another form of intelligence it's across
the intelligence right and to be smart
is concluded intelligence would you
agree with me that this technique is not
smart well the Bible says you know thank
you Gene the the Bible says that the
fool has said on his heart there is no
God and the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of wisdom and Satan's not
fearing God
is a sign of the ultimate ignorance
and I know that that might sound like a
contradiction but keep in mind
there are some people in the world that
have extremely high IQs
that do not believe in God and they are
foolish
in deliberately choosing not to believe
in God I think Paul addresses this in
Romans 1 he says thinking themselves why
is they become fools
and so they're still very intelligent
people that would you know if they took
an IQ test they'd score very high if you
ask them if they believe in God they say
no the reason is they can't afford to
believe in God because that means they
would have to answer to God they want to
be their own God that was the devil's
problem
and so when it says the serpent was more
cunning it's talking about the
craftiness the hypnotic ability of like
a snake to deceive to sneak up on
so um it doesn't mean that the devil is
wise in the spiritual sense real wisdom
is surrendering to God and believing in
God
all right thank you next holiday that we
have is uh lorendo listening from New
York Loretta welcome to the program
hey Doug and John hi my question is my
13 year old came to me with these two
verses and he was wondering if there's a
contradiction clearly I couldn't explain
it to him it's second chronicles 22 2
and second Kings 8 26. okay let's go
there second chronicles 22 2. yeah
um and the inhabitants of Jerusalem
media his Ayah his youngest son King
this place for the Raiders who came with
the Arabians and the camp had killed the
older Sons so as I the son of joram King
of Judah reigned
um and so a verse through Isaiah was 42
years old now
um the in Second Kings it says is I was
22 years old
yeah and the reason that is given by the
Bible scholars is that it probably was
that he was 22 years old
um the letters in Hebrew the Bible is
perfect but sometimes the manuscripts
they translate from the scribes had
written letters not clearly or the ink
had smudged by the time the translators
got the documents and when they looked
at the Hebrew letters for 22 it's like
in English the seven and the two can
sometimes look similar if you don't
write them clearly you know what I'm
saying
and a matter of fact when I was um
when I was a teenager I took my
learner's permit I was born in 1957 now
you all know how old I am but I wanted
to be able to buy alcohol so I turned
the seven into a two very easily and I
use that counterfeit or forged learner's
permit to get a driver's license for
years my driver's license said I was
older than I was even after I became a
Christian because every time I renewed
it they took the old date and one day I
went back and I said you know this is
wrong that's not my age and they just
took my word for it and changed it back
I was amazed I should have said I was
15. anyway but
um this is just a place where you are
going to see a discrepancy because is
this what you understand Pastor Ross
that the numbers in Hebrew the
characters look very similar and it was
translated
incorrectly probably in second
chronicles 22.
so thank you hope that end of math adds
up better one way than the other as far
as the ages of the Kings and how old the
kids would be
all right next goal that we have is uh
Jasmine listening Georgia Jasmine
welcome to the program
uh yes good night I just wanted to say
uh God bless your ministry
and my son and I hear you guys every day
you know repetition but our question
that we have is when Eve was talking to
the serpent why was she not surprised
that the serpent was talking to her
well I think she was surprised I think
the the devil deliberately uh possessed
this beautiful subtle uh creature
that it was probably hypnotic in the way
it moved even snakes today can be
hypnotic but snakes after sin were
cursed to crawl on the ground which
means before sin
they had some other memes of
mobilization and commentators think that
they may have been able to fly
virtually every culture in the world
talks about flying reptiles and there's
even
bones of pterodactyls and pterodactyls
and reptiles that flew so you know we
don't know if there's that connection
but I think she was surprised and that's
one of the things that sure she wasn't
afraid there was nothing in the garden
to fear
but I don't think he even knew that any
of the creatures had the ability of
speech and the serpent is he's
intimating if you eat this fruit look
what it did for me I was a snake that
all I could do is stick out my tongue
and now I can talk
and she was amazed by that and thought
maybe God is keeping something from us
so I do I don't know what your thoughts
are right absolutely I think he I think
she was surprised I was probably
surprised by the fact that it almost
seemed as though the serpent answered a
question that she was wondering about
she was looking at the fruit the devil
was waiting he saw his perfect
opportunity and he read her expressions
of curiosity and yeah subtle yeah and
then you know I heard one Hebrew scholar
said
when he greeted Eve it was like hi there
I mean it was all yeah it was almost
like a flattering seductive greeting
that appealed to her
so uh yeah okay
thanks next Call of that we have is Kobe
listening from Washington Kobe welcome
to Bible answers live
hello pastors hi
I wanted to know can uh
can people
go to heaven if they go to church on
Sunday
okay
uh there are going to be a lot of people
in heaven that went to church on Sunday
they'll be people in heaven that maybe
didn't know what day to go to church now
I think Kobe might be wondering because
on this program we've said that
biblically there's no question the
seventh day is the Sabbath well what
does that mean about millions of people
around the world that go to church on
the first day of the week instead of the
seventh day are they automatically lost
no
sin is knowing to do good and not doing
it so there's a lot of people that don't
know God's will in this area and so uh
you know Christians that live up to all
the light that they have they're going
to be in the Kingdom
um but that doesn't mean we should
ignore what the Bible says once we know
what the Bible says we need to follow
the word of God well the Bible speaks of
a time when God winked at their
ignorance for example you have many uh
very Godly men in the Old Testament that
had more than one wife well that was
never God's will Jesus made very clear
when he said in the beginning he created
man woman and yet they still going to be
saved they kind of conform to the
culture of the time and uh
God has given us truth we want to follow
all the light yep so thank you Kobe hope
that helps to answer that a little bit
we've got
um Stephen listening Canada Stephen
welcome to the program
yes good evening gentlemen I appreciate
the program as always time I have a
pleasure to call thank you for taking my
call but I would like to know what's the
survivors here about fortification you
know to keep Act of making love outside
of marriage uh I think the Bible is
pretty clear that sexual relations for
people are to be reserved for the
marriage covenant
and I think we can see the epidemic in
our country and other parts of the world
to families where children are born into
single-parent families not because the
father or mother died but because there
was no benefit of a covenant of marriage
and they grow up and often struggle with
a whole spectrum of problems because
they don't have the biblically designed
family now I know they're people that
either through divorce or death they're
single parents and and God will watch
over and bless but it's not the ideal
God's ideal is for there to be man and
woman sex is to be reserved for that and
you might be thinking well what if you
know if you use birth control what
difference does it make you know God
wants us to reserve those intimate uh
that intimate gift for the marriage
covenant and I think the Bible every
verse in the Bible that addresses that
is consistent
all right did you have a second question
Stephen
yes because
thank you very much uh professors my
second question is that you should not
add or discharge anything as evaluation
crisis but my humble observation because
the Sabbath is going to be the Seal of
God and also Isaiah 66 32 33 as you know
it's going to be an eternal life
importance is this can keep us more on
the normal path more in Christ than
let's say Sunday which is not in the
Bible or you know any other day uh you
know the Saturdays keep us more clean
more pure bride of Christ the same for
you know more being different men and
more the desire to stay pure until the
marriage well I I do think there's
benefit whenever we obey God there's a
blessing if you look in Isaiah Chapter
58 when it talks about the Sabbath
commandment in particular and um you can
look in let me see here
uh
here we go I'm getting close Isaiah 58
verse 13. if you turn away your foot
from the Sabbath from doing your
pleasure on my holy day and call the
Sabbath a delight the holy day of the
Lord honorable and shall honor him not
doing your own ways or finding your own
pleasure or speaking your own words then
you will delight yourself in the Lord
and I will cause you to ride on the high
places of the earth and feed you with
the heritage of Jacob your father the
mouth of the Lord has spoken he promises
special blessings that go above and
beyond the blessings of physical rest
you know we have a study guide It's
called The Lost day of history and if
anyone wants to study this further it's
an important topic we'll be able to send
you this for free the number to call is
800-835-6747 just ask for the study
guide called the last day of History we
also have a website called
sabbathtruth.com and you can go there
right away and you can see some great
resources and study this further for
yourself next holiday we have is Lee
listening in Texas Lee welcome to the
program thank you
yes sir thank you
that um that God knows right
well yes he does now on Earth he did not
I mean on Earth he laid aside his
divinity
and so he only knew that what was
revealed at no time by the father
Jesus once said that he doesn't know the
day the day it is coming but how could
he not know the day of his own coming if
he knew everything that God does well
when he does know now but when Christ
was on Earth as a man he had the
Incarnation I mean think about it for a
moment when Jesus was a baby in the
manger do you think he had all the
knowledge of the cosmos and all the
knowledge of God swirling around his
head he had to learn to talk like other
babies so and it says in is it
Philippians where it says he laid aside
his divinity
uh he thought it not Robert E to be
equal with God it might be thinking
Colossians
but made himself of no reputation taking
on the form of a servant so
Christ basically when he was on Earth as
a human and he said that no one knows
the day of the hour I don't even know
um for one opinions Philippians 2 7.
yeah what would Jesus say to the
apostles would he say yeah February 26
1945 is when I'm coming or 2045.
what would that mean to them I mean how
would he even relate the date they
didn't have that dating method so does
Jesus know the day in the office coming
of course I mean you can't picture Jesus
Is Up in Heaven by the father and he's
saying please let me know when am I
supposed to come nope can't show you yet
can't trust you of course he knows but
on Earth as a man yeah
all right thank you next holiday that we
have is Cindy listening in Arizona Cindy
welcome to uh Bible answers live hold on
a second we just
had Cindy move real quick do you have it
there Pastor Doug uh we've got callers
come in so it shifts our names
well let's oh there it is I found okay
Cindy in Arizona Cindy welcome to the
program
hi can you hear me we do
is around uh the crying of blood from
the ground The Filling of innocent blood
um and the crying out from the from the
grave like Abel in Genesis 4 and then I
um
I I had mentioned Matthew to I think
it's 218 actually where it mentions
Rachel yes the last part of that
yeah but um I was wondering about
Revelation I think it's 9 through 10.
um because the soul of those under the
altar crying out
yeah and it's connection to abortion and
you know the sixth commandment
um not killing so do you think that
those are the
63 plus million
and squirrel versus Wade 1973.
um do you think that could be yeah I
think I understand what you're asking
Cindy you know when
when God said to Cain the blood of your
brother Abel cries to me from the ground
he meant the blood isn't little blood
cells aren't you know squeaking it
wasn't talking about literally it's a
figure of speech that the innocent blood
of Abel was crying out for justice
you've got the innocent blood of the
children in the story of the slaughter
in Bethlehem crying out for justice
Jesus had all the blood from Abel to
Zechariah the son of barakai who is An
Innocent Prophet killed in Jerusalem was
going to come on that generation and it
did with the destruction of Jerusalem
when you read in Revelation is it
chapter nine where it's the souls under
the altar is that five chapter six
chapter six when you read about the
souls under the altar
um it's again it's a symbol for the
martyrs those who have died for the
cause of Christ but the the innocent
blood of uh unborn children that is also
crying out for justice that verse in
particular I don't think he's talking
about that
but certainly God is a record of um on
any Injustice and innocent blood and
there'll be a Payday for that yeah from
the broader context you know we're
talking about the facile in the sequence
of events if you kind of follow through
the chronology talking about a time of
severe persecution That Came Upon
bible-believing Christians during the
time of the reformation and even before
and that fits into that time frame could
refer to you know the broader aspect of
of just uh innocent life being taken
possibly principles specifically yeah
it's relating to to the modest during
that time period thank you Cindy hope
that helps a little and maybe we have
time for one more before our first sign
off all right we've got Daryl listening
in Florida Daryl welcome to the program
hey Pastor Doug and Pastor Jean um so we
know that God and God only can forgive
sin but uh how do we reconcile when
Jesus gave the disciples the authority
to forgive sin in John chapter 20 verse
23 and then
uh once he gives them that Authority it
was only was it only those disciples or
was it from that point forward that
Jesus if you were a disciple of Jesus
you had the ability to forgive sin and
then the next idea that comes into my
head maybe this is why some certain
priests think they have the ability to
forgive people's sins yeah let me quote
this for our friends that are listening
and this is in Matthew chapter I'm sorry
John chapter 20 verse 22. it says and
when he said this he breathed on them
and said to them receive the Holy Spirit
if you forgive the sins of any they are
forgiven of them if you retain the sins
of any they are retained now that has
been quoted by the Catholic church and
probably others as proof that Apostles
and Priests can forgive sins but
I do believe that Christians can forgive
you know keep in mind Christ says when
you bring your gift to the altar if you
have ought with your brother it could be
reconciled your brother and in the
Lord's Prayer it says forgive us our
debt says we forgive our debtor so
there's a way for us to forgive each
other offenses against us in preaching
the gospel we are passing on the
Forgiveness of God to others in
neglecting to preach the gospel
they're not having that benefit so in as
much as Apostles and Believers share the
gospel of forgiveness people receive
forgiveness and when we fail to do that
or neglect to do that they are they're
uh they lose that benefit
I don't know what are your thoughts yeah
absolutely I think it also has a
reference here to church Authority or
church leadership yeah not that the
church can forgive or not forgive but if
somebody is living in open violation and
the church has spoken to them and they
refuse to repent and the church decides
to remove them from membership that is a
serious thing and Christ did give his
church the ability to in that case
protect uh the flock and also be
faithful to the truth to the word yeah
Matthew 18 18 whatever you bind on Earth
will be bound on Heaven whatever you
loose on Earth will be loose in heaven
and that's in the context of the church
church forgiving yeah I hope that helps
listening friends now I always like to
explain just so people understand Bible
answers live is on hundreds of stations
on the internet we're on satellite radio
and we're on land base stations because
of the clocks we sign off on satellite
first
so we'll say God bless and farewell to
all those listening on satellite radio
but we're going to stay by and do rapid
fire Bible questions in just a moment so
don't go anywhere we are coming back
foreign
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live for those of you who are
staying around for the next few minutes
we can answer some of the email
questions that you sent us if you'd like
to send us an email question our email
address is Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org
pass it out first question that we have
it's a tough one it says how do you
handle or how do I handle my 31 year old
daughter who is now transitioning into a
man
well
you know that's heartbreaking and if
you're asking for a Bible answer I would
say that uh you know we need to love
people obviously you don't love uh sin
and you certainly don't love where
someone might be going through a medical
or chemical procedures to try to alter
their gender because it's really it's an
effort of futility you cannot alter your
gender the the the genes of men and
women are different all the way down to
the very basic level the chromosomes and
so they're finding out more and more
people that are trying to transition are
now trying to untransition because
they're not finding the Fulfillment I
would say just be there to show
unconditional love while I know you
don't approve of sin and what your
values are you want to support them as a
human being so you're there for them
afterward if they're looking for for
love and and uh encouragement okay very
good here's another question and is
asking she said did God breathe the
breath of life into all animals as well
yeah that breath of life that God it
says God formed Adam from The Elements
of the Earth the clay he breathed in his
nostrils the breath of life and Man
became a living soul
um yes that Breath of Life was not only
given to man but you read in
Ecclesiastes that when any creature dies
the breath it says the spirit returns to
God who gave it and the body returns to
the Earth
and so the body decomposes and the
Breath of Life returns to God and that
says
to man and beasts and Ecclesiastes they
have the Breath of Life obviously okay
another question shawny's asking are we
to be afraid of evil spirits
no first of all Jesus said fear not fear
not fear not fear not uh you know I
don't think we should dabble with or try
to confront or communicate with evil
spirits
but just know they're there
good news is there's more good spirits
than evil spirits meaning there's more
good angels and evil angels
and so um yeah the Bible tells us he
that is in you is greater than he that
is in the world so we don't need to be
afraid of the devil resist the devil
he'll flee from you friends God bless we
hope that you will return next week as
we continue to study God's word
answers live honest and accurate answers
to your Bible questions